[SPEAKER_00]: Third of Wealsun.
[SPEAKER_00]: As the sun sets in the west, Gouge pulls him out of the bar to an alleyway and sits him down to have a little talk.
[SPEAKER_02]: Know what you're trying to do?
[SPEAKER_02]: Did you like the song?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, fucking loved it actually, but saw it didn't go over while reading the room.
[SPEAKER_02]: And took it upon myself to get your ass out of there the best way I could.
[SPEAKER_02]: Everyone was kind of stunned looking at you.
[SPEAKER_02]: So I made a bigger scene.
[SPEAKER_02]: Showing a little blade and grabbing you and taking you out.
[SPEAKER_02]: Obviously looked at Ty because they know he was with you.
[SPEAKER_02]: Told them to sit the fuck down.
[SPEAKER_02]: Just to know that's being handled in case there was any bad blood from this.
[SPEAKER_02]: So this will blow over.
[SPEAKER_02]: But this was my one for you pulling you out because I didn't want it to get any worse.
[SPEAKER_02]: And here I thought I was ending my life.
[SPEAKER_02]: My life was ending.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, you guys do have maybe a little bit of preconceived notion of
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't know who I am or what I am, but remember when I shouted out and you thought I was the asshole?
[SPEAKER_02]: It is Jude.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's not Jude, okay?
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, I'll follow the law, and it is, and there's no reason.
[SPEAKER_02]: No.
[SPEAKER_02]: You have no reason to fear me unless you cross somebody besides me that I'm loyal to.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's the only thing we should fear.
[SPEAKER_02]: Fair enough.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, I appreciate you getting me out there.
[SPEAKER_02]: You want them here for this little next bit?
[SPEAKER_00]: Tyrus walks out and you find the two of them in an alleyway.
[SPEAKER_00]: Gouge actually has his arm around Folsom's shoulder and is talking to him in not a mean way.
[SPEAKER_00]: You're not sure if that's a good sign or not.
[SPEAKER_02]: So I see him come up.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm just gonna throw up Knuckles to him.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is this part where I get stabbed?
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll tell Ty.
[SPEAKER_01]: Great song, but not the best crowd, brother.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Hey, I read the room and pulled them out, and that was just all for show to get them out.
[SPEAKER_01]: I told him it was a joke and bought him all more beer, so I think that'll cure a lot.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: Where's Mary?
[SPEAKER_01]: Did you leave him in there?
[SPEAKER_01]: I did.
[SPEAKER_01]: He was talking to Owen, so...
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you mind?
[SPEAKER_02]: You guys...
[SPEAKER_02]: Don't have business in the barracks, or do you?
[SPEAKER_01]: No, let's find it with a bar.
[SPEAKER_01]: Can you go grab Merrick?
[SPEAKER_02]: I got a word with him.
[SPEAKER_02]: We'll be here, come back, and we'll clear these guys with what he just did, and go have a couple.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I'll head back to the bar then?
[SPEAKER_00]: Do I need to head back to- Well, you head back, and actually when you walk in, you see Merrick just shaking Owen's hand and moving towards the door.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I'll just casually step outside the door?
[SPEAKER_01]: So you have to say something in the private room?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh.
[SPEAKER_01]: So we'll step out here.
[SPEAKER_02]: It'll be basically something.
[SPEAKER_02]: Ancient cloak.
[SPEAKER_02]: There's a green stone here.
[SPEAKER_02]: Quite the gem you have here.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't use this as it should be used.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay?
[SPEAKER_02]: But this thing is probably going to make your songs just a little bit better.
[SPEAKER_02]: Understood.
[SPEAKER_02]: But this comes with a price if you accept this.
[SPEAKER_02]: The price being?
[SPEAKER_02]: The price being, if we're together and we're in combat and stuff's happening and you're gonna play your tunes or whatever you're gonna do to benefit somebody, I want you to look at me first before you decide.
[SPEAKER_02]: And I'm fair.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay?
[SPEAKER_02]: And you can trust me.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's up to you whether believe it or not.
[SPEAKER_02]: But listen,
[SPEAKER_02]: When you're gonna throw out something to help somebody or do something, I want you to look at me.
[SPEAKER_02]: If I give a nod, like no, that means I don't need shit.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's all on you.
[SPEAKER_02]: But if you look at me and I'm like, fuck, that means whatever you're doing, you better fucking help me.
[SPEAKER_02]: Understood.
[SPEAKER_02]: You okay with that deal?
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm more than okay with that deal.
[SPEAKER_02]: All right.
[SPEAKER_02]: I owe you one.
[SPEAKER_02]: Or a few.
[SPEAKER_02]: We'll see.
[SPEAKER_02]: Hopefully none, but I'm not that lucky.
[SPEAKER_02]: Or maybe some red-eye.
Ferds is it.
It is.
All right.